viewers argentina is not exactly having
its best moment
[Applause]
[Music]
mauricio macri's government has had to
ask for a bailout from the international
monetary fund and the truth is that in
the last few decades
crises devaluations inflation and
payment suspensions have become
commonplace
in argentina's politics and economy well
throughout this entire process
one political movement has had absolute
influence peronism
but alright what exactly is this
political stream known
as peronism how did it come about and
what impact has it really had on
argentina well we're going to talk about
it all on visualpolitik in
two videos and in the first one we're
going to focus on its origins
and its identity so listen up
first of all who was juan domingo peran
and most importantly how did he manage
to gain power and
influence in argentine politics for
seven decades
well to begin this story we have to go
all the way back to the 1930s at that
time
argentine nationalism was in its golden
age
[Music]
[Applause]
argentina was undoubtedly latin
america's great power despite the 1929
crisis it was still one of the 10
richest countries in the world and wages
were much
much higher than in europe
however wait a second here because in
spite of this the 1929 crisis had taken
its toll hitting the country hard
the tension led to the first military
coup in 1930 a coup
supported by many political economic and
social sectors
especially on the conservative side of
things
[Music]
and under this militaristic
authoritarian and nationalist panorama
it became
customary for many officers of the
argentine army to be
sent to germany and italy to take
advanced courses
and viewer do you know who one of these
officers was
well yeah that would be juan domingo
peron who was sent to italy a country
where he met
and studied first-hand how benito
mussolini's government
was organized and you know what soon
after he'd get the chance to put this
knowledge
right into practice
you see at the beginning of the 1940s
argentina was under the control of a
corrupt and authoritarian government a
government that had perpetuated
electoral fraud and attempted to stay in
power at all costs
[Music]
under these circumstances on june the
4th 1943 a group of young
officers in the argentine army held a
coup d'etat supposedly to restore
a transparent electoral system one of
these officers was
our protagonist lieutenant colonel juan
domingo peron
by the way this was argentina's second
coup d'etat after the 1930s one but
don't think it was its last certainly
not the case during the next 30 years
the country suffered
four more coups
the case is dear viewers that it was
this 1943 coup which opened the doors to
politics and power for lieutenant
colonel juan domingo peron we can
practically say that this is where
argentina's modern history began
so listen up
[Music]
during the two and a half years that the
military government lasted perron's
career was
meteoric this was despite the fact that
until then it held a very low rank
positions such as head of the department
of labor a position that in principle
was
how do i say it rather bureaucratic
however hold on a second because thanks
to his political intelligence peron
managed to use this position as a
springboard for his rise to power you
see from the very beginning juan domingo
peron
used everything he'd learned under
benito mussolini in italy
starting by winning some of the union's
support
that way each time the labor department
had to intervene in a conflict between
employers and unions related to perron
the former the
employers would almost always lose as
you can imagine this meant that this
man's popularity didn't
stop growing
[Music]
in fact shortly after peran was
appointed minister of war
and then vice president all without
forgetting the labor policies and the
unions
because if something was very very clear
to this lieutenant colonel it was
that that would be his political
springboard
[Music]
but he wasn't the only one aspiring to
power and so much prominence led to a
lot of jealousy
so much so that the military leaders
asked him to move away from the
government
in 1945. so we could perhaps expect this
to be the end
of this military man's political career
right well
no nothing could be further from the
truth
[Music]
perron had learned how much influence
the media could have in europe so he
asked his superiors if he could say
goodbye through the national radio
network
they naively accepted and peron took
full advantage of this opportunity
in his farewell message he thanked the
working classes for their support and
questioned the continuity of the social
benefits that he'd promoted
is
[Applause]
foreign
it had a huge effect in the following
days the unions mobilized in his favor
and on october the 17th
thousands of workers occupied the plaza
de mayo the nerve center
of argentine politics
[Music]
the government disorientated by the way
events unfolded
asked the lieutenant colonel himself to
appease the masses
and this is something he did but only
after agreeing that he'd be a candidate
in the next elections he also made sure
that he had the support
of the public powers
[Music]
juan domingo peron had managed to become
a candidate but now he needed
to win the election as we've seen
at the time argentina was under military
control so government authorization was
required to hold
meetings and electoral acts were no
exception
of course peron's campaign actions were
almost automatically authorized while
his opponents well
let's just say the process was much
slower and not only that but perron also
had complete access to the most
important means of communication at the
time the national radio station because
it was owned by the government
but that's not all under peron's
insistence the government approved paid
vacations for all workers as well as
additional salary at the end of the year
these are all things that make you look
very good to your electorate and there
was still a move this genius of
political strategies managed to use
very well you see the state department
of the united states itself
intervened in peron's rivals campaigns
publishing a report known as the blue
book where peron's activities and those
of his military allies were
shown to support the nazi regime
[Music]
however perron managed to turn this
around and morph it into something like
a struggle between himself who
represented
argentine's sovereignty in the united
states in the end all these tactics
copied years later by populist
governments throughout latin america won
the elections for perron
the victory it wasn't overwhelming but
it was enough
a very important fact here when juan
domingo peron came to government
argentina was one of the 10 most
prosperous and
richest economies in the world the
country was even an
international creditor countries like
the united kingdom
actually owed it money thanks to all of
this the new president had more than
enough resources to launch his political
program
a program based on three pillars
political sovereignty economic
independence
and social justice in practice he
transformed argentina into a kind
of army under the command of a single
leader its president
[Music]
thus peron managed to nationalize a lot
of companies especially those related to
public services
such as transport energy and
communications he also placed banking
under governmental control and approved
a lot of foreign trade restrictions
and he also achieved a lot of popular
support so how did he do it well he did
it by maintaining
utility rates even below their cost and
hiring a lot of employees for the
government
and for governmental companies and it's
certainly not so much of a coincidence
that the kirchners 60 years later did
practically the same thing
of course all of this involved a lot of
spending and well how do you think he
financed it
of course he started printing money and
this is where the addiction of
argentinian politicians printing bills
came from
the fact is that during the first years
of this entire process and
thanks to all the money that he injected
into the economy things
seemed to be actually sailing pretty
smoothly so what was the problem well
it simply wasn't sustainable the
government overspent and the country's
competitiveness began to sink
like the titanic within a few years
their positive balance
vanished private investment collapsed
and suddenly some prices
started to skyrocket
[Music]
so what do you think happened then do
you think that given that his revolution
didn't seem to be on the right track
perron would take a bit of the blame
well no he didn't at all in fact he
blamed alleged speculators of attacking
the national economy
and to remedy all of this he multiplied
the government controls regulated prices
and
implemented all kinds of measures that
would even affect bread distribution
but dear viewer the crisis wasn't
peron's only problem the 1853
constitution didn't allow for a
politician to stay in power preventing
an immediate re-election so under this
scenario what do you think he did well
listen to this
[Applause]
along with the bill printing machine
latin american politician's second
favorite toy
is constituent reforms and of course
perron was
no exception in 1949 since the previous
constitution imposed too many obstacles
iran
launched a complete constitutional
reform the new constitution placed the
state as the fundamental pillar of
argentine society
even in the constitution's own preamble
the three pillars of juan domingo
peron's political thesis were included
this
was supposed to be a constitution for
all but let's take a look at the
change's results
investments had disappeared the macro
data just got worse the country was in
crisis
and public companies in argentina
underwent what the pdvsa
the venezuelan state-owned oil and
natural gas company underwent they
simply weren't invested in so they
suffered from all kinds of influences
and in the end they were very
unproductive and inefficient
all to the detriment of the argentines
in other words the new model juan
domingo peron had implemented became
a poverty-making machine of course this
all happened under the enormous cult
of this leader the reality to viewer is
that argentine society was in crisis and
it was so fragmented that under these
circumstances in september of 1955 there
was a new coup d'etat
this time it was against juan domingo
peron
[Laughter]
[Music]
a
so you now might be thinking well this
is the end of perron well if you're
thinking that you're actually mistaken
but we're going to talk about all of
that in a future video and i really hope
you enjoyed this video if you did please
do hit that like button and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for brand
new videos also please do check out our
patreon our channel is possible
because of the people who support us
over there so find a link to that in the
description below
and as always thank you for watching